O
BRING YOU SOME TOP RACES THAT
"THE ANGLE" IS KEEPING ITS ION.
TONIGHT WE ARE HITTING THE BIG
BOARD FOR OUR RETAKING AMERICA
SEGMENT.
JOINING ME NOW, CHRIS BEDFORD,
EXECUTIVE EDITOR FOR THE
COMMON SENSE SOCIETY.
LET'S START IN THE SENATE WERE
REPUBLICANS NEED 1 SEED TO TAKE
CONTROL.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
WISCONSIN WHERE G.O.P. INCUMBENT
RON JOHNSON IS FACING A
CHALLENGE FROM PRETTY RADICAL
GUY, MANDELLA BARNES.
>> A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO PRETEND WISCONSIN
ISN'T ON THE LOT OF TROUBLE.
I'VE NEVER REALLY BOUGHT IT.
MANDELA BARNES IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO IS
CHARISMATIC, HANDSOME, YOUNG,
LOOKS THE PART OF A POLITICIAN.
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T LOOK UNDER THE
HOOD.
HE IS PRETTY RADICAL.
WISCONSIN IS BACK AND FORTH.
OBAMA, TRUMP, BIDEN.
THIS IS NOT SOMEONE THAT YOU CAN
RUN AS A RADICAL LEFTIST AND
THAT SEEMS TO BE A PROBLEM HE'S
RUNNING INTO.
>> Laura: YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE EXTREME VIEWS, LET'S
GO THROUGH SOME OF THEM.
HE FAVORS ELIMINATING CASH BAIL.
TODAY WITH THE CRIME, HOW IS
THAT FLYING?
>> IT'S NOT.
WE WERE IN WISCONSIN REPORTING
BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTION AND
THERE'S ONE THING AFTER THE
WHOLE SUMMER AND EVERYTHING TO
PUT A SIGN PROFESSING YOUR
INNOCENCE FOR JOINING A
POLITICAL CAUSE IN YOUR WINDOW
BUT IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN THEY
ARE BURNING DOWN KENOSHA, THE
HOTEL STAFF IN MILWAUKEE HAS TO
SAY MOVE YOUR CAR BECAUSE
RIOTERS WILL BE HERE TONIGHT.
PEOPLE WERE EXTREMELY UPSET.
DEMOCRATS MIGHT'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PULL IT OUT BECAUSE THERE WAS
DISTASTE FOR DONALD TRUMP AMONG
SUBURBAN WOMEN VOTERS BUT
DESPITE DEMOCRATS BEST EFFORTS,
TRUMP IS NOT ON THE BALLOT.
HIS POLICIES ARE ON THE BALLOT.
RELEASING CRIMINALS, THAT'S NOT
A POPULAR POSITION.
SPEECH OR TALKING ABOUT OF
RAPISTS AND MURDERERS.
HIS VIEWS ARE EXTREME BUT IS IT
OUT OF STEP WITH WISCONSIN?
>> THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN RON JOHNSON BEING ABLE
TO DEFINE HIS OPPONENT.
SENATOR RELEASING ADVERTISEMENTS
THAT TAKE THE ADS.
HE SAID ACTING LIKE A BASEBALL
AND HITTING NORMAL -- HIS
POLICIES ARE FOR CUTTING POLICE.
HE SAYS AMERICA IS AN AWFUL
COUNTING.
HE SAYS THE GREEN NEW DEAL
SHOULD COME TO WISCONSIN.
>> Laura: TYPICAL DEMOCRAT.
LET'S TURN TO THE HOUSE WHERE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT HENRY CUELLAR
IS BATTLING A NEWCOMER IN THE
TEXAS DISTRICT.
>> HENRY CUELLAR IS THE LAST
PRO-LIFE DEMOCRAT LEFT.
HE'S BEEN YELLING AT THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THE BORDER COME
HE IS A NINE TERM CONGRESSMAN
RUNNING AGAINST AN OPENLY
CONSERVATIVE TED CRUZ STAFFER.
THIS USED TO BE THE FUTURE OF
THE DEMOCRAT PLANS.
THEY WROTE BOOKS ABOUT HOW THE
CHANGES GOING TO USHER IN A
DEMOCRATIC SUPERMAJORITY.
IT'S GROUND ZERO.
DEMOCRATS KEEP ON ATTACKING THE
BORDER.
IT'S HURTING DEMOCRATS.
HE'S HAD SUPPORT FOR DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP BUT IN GENERAL THIS
IS A SHOWING A CONTINUING TREND
OF HISPANIC VOTERS TURNING ON
DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: THIS PRIMARY WENT TO
A RUNOFF AND THEN A RECOUNT.
HE MAY HAVE LOST IF THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP DIDN'T
STEP IN TO HELP HIM EVEN THOUGH
HE'S AT ODDS WITH DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP ON MOST OF THESE BIG
ISSUES.
SEMIAUTOMATIC BAN.
WHY DO THEY WANT HIM TO WIN IF
HE'S JUST GOING TO BE A RUBBER
STAMP?
>> OVER 40% AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT 60% IS HELPFUL.
THE RIO GRANDE IS GOING MORE AND
MORE RED.
THE YOUNG WOMAN IS A RADICAL
LEFT-WINGER.
DEMOCRAT SAID THERE'S NO SHOT
SHE'S GOING TO WIN AND THE
GENERAL ELECTION AND MAYBE WE
CAN GET SOME CONCESSIONS FROM
HENRY CUELLAR.
BUT IT'S NEVER GOOD FOR AN
INCUMBENT TO ALMOST BARELY
SCRAPE BY IN THE PRIMARY.
>> Laura: A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THEY SAID BETO O'ROURKE WILL BE
AT THE FOREFRONT OF FLIPPING
TEXAS TO BLUE.
I THINK WE SAW THAT HEADLINE SO
MANY TIMES.
>> THEY ARE STILL DOING THINK
PIECES.
NOW WE HAVE MANDELA BARNES.
>> Laura: LET'S STAY IN SOUTH
TEXAS.
G.O.P. CONGRESSWOMAN IS BATTLING
A DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN IN THE
34TH DISTRICT.
SHE IS RUNNING FOR HER FIRST
FULL TERM AFTER SHE WON THE
SPECIAL ELECTION.
THIS REALLY DOES SEEM LIKE A
HISPANIC WAVE IN SOME SECTIONS
OF THE COUNTRY FOR REPUBLICANS.
>> THE FIRST MEXICAN-AMERICAN
WOMAN ELECTED TO CONGRESS FOR A
SPECIAL TERM.
SHE'S THE FIRST REPUBLICAN IN
HISTORY ELECTED TO HER OWN
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT BECAUSE OF
REWRITING, THESE TWO INCUMBENTS
ARE FORCED TO FACE OFF AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND I THINK SHE'S GOT
A REAL SHOT.
DEMOCRATS IN TEXAS KIND OF RUN
TO THE RIGHT OF THE REPUBLICANS
IN MASSACHUSETTS.
IT'S NOT A LEFT-WING STATE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT DEMOCRATS
ARE IN TROUBLE WITH RIGHT-WING
CHALLENGERS.
OECD, THE POLITICAL REPORT SAID
IT'S LEANING TOWARDS MYRA.
THE SUMMER OF JOE BIDEN WITH HIS
AVIATORS, THAT SEEMS TO BE
PUTTERING OUT IN REAL TIME.
>> Laura: THE NUMBER ONE STATE
THAT COULD BE A BELLWETHER FOR
AN ABSOLUTE REPUBLICAN WAVE
WOULD BE WHAT?
LET'S SEE A GUBERNATORIAL RACE.
IF IT WENT TO REPUBLIC, WHICH
WOULD PRESIDE TO REPUBLICAN
WAVE?
>> OREGON.
>> Laura: IT'S GOT TO BE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST.
IF THAT GOES RED, ALL BE